[Music]
Taylor is going to sing carpool karaoke
hey Gordon come on what do you want her
to sing you know what I love exactly
karaoke special James Corden's airs
tonight with Jennifer Lopez yeah the
late-night host has definitely gone
primetime but we love him because he's
still humble to top ten to eleven
Maestri when you get up I'm coming
special that means the bosses are fans -
you know that right yes I guess you
can't argue with that that's very true
yes we're although we did just think
maybe they just got an hour to fail and
I don't want to do it oh don't be too
modest James people have been checking
you out in big numbers a downed at 89
million YouTube views one direction 55
million cordons YouTube channel over 800
million views then there's tonight halo
all leading up to a copper which halo
how did that happen well I think we just
asked didn't she said yeah who's the
most famous person listen no I don't
know I stole her cell phone you've never
seen more famous people in a photo alive
Dwayne the rock I sent a text to the
most famous person on the planet and
they responded James is pretty famous
himself as I could see on our little
walk across the line and anyone really
starstruck
yeah well you never think that you're
gonna you know meet Stevie Wonder
singing out in John's hip I sort of
think if these were auction prizes they
would go for hundreds of thousands of
dollars and yet this is my job you know
James told me it takes an hour and a
half to take a 15-minute carpool karaoke
so I asked him why don't we get to see
all of those outtakes right and he said
I want to leave the people wanting more